today's new member of the day is Ruben
Aguilar Ruben thank you so much for
being a david pakman show member and I
would encourage all of our viewers and
listeners to sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership the best way to support
this program's existence is by becoming
a member on our website ok we do have
hatred mail today I'll remind you what
hatred mail is to begin with a fine Rand
and Ronald Reagan had a baby and suckled
that child off the teat of Liberty its
cries would sound a little something
like Patriot written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America
because freedom so I don't really even
think this week's hatred mail needs much
of an introduction it's pretty
self-explanatory let's take a listen i
watch your show because i like to stay
informed and what the liberal morons are
saying you disparaged a Navy SEAL who
was nearly killed during the slaughter
at Benghazi during your video in which
your frail girly arms were on display as
you spat on the integrity of a man who
put his life on the line to defend the
country you asked whether his account
would change anyone's opinion on Clinton
my answer to that is who the hell else
would if not his he was there numbnuts
here's a bit of advice scrawny go and
join the military since they're
accepting transsexuals now maybe you can
say you're a woman to meet lower
physical fitness standards then get
shipped off to whatever hellhole Obama
feckless Li wanders next you've always
been an absurd host but never have you
been this wretched presented I think for
today without commentary because how
could I possibly follow that up except
to say that we figured out a way to turn
the hate reott ism into something good
we have a coupon code hey tree at 40
which you can use at david pakman.com
slash membership for a very nice
discount off of your membership and i
guesses
the hatreds don't like knowing that
their ad homonyms and insults are turned
into a way to actually support and grow
the show